there is a growing backlash over a
landmark ruling against Olympic
gold-medalist caster Semenya the sports
world's highest court ruled yesterday
that Semenya must take medication to
reduce her unusually high testosterone
level if she wants to compete the court
called his decision on the South African
runner acceptable discrimination Debora
patta is in Johannesburg and shows us
their growing support for Semenya Debora
good morning good morning South Africans
are rallying behind caster Semenya with
many saying she's being punished for
being too fast and not conforming to
Western standards of what a female
athlete should look like for 10 years
caster Semenya has been trying to outrun
the global controversy that's written to
cut her career short the two-time
Olympic champion has repeatedly been
forced to verify her gender and battle
claims that her naturally elevated
testosterone gives her an unfair
advantage
the ruling bans women athletes like
salmon with testosterone levels above
the average female range from running
distances up to a mile
unless they take potentially harmful
medication to reduce that testosterone
law professor Steve Cornelius says this
is immoral so immoral he resigned last
year from the I double-a if in protest
you're actually taking out the person
and turning that person into a patient
hormone specialist dr. Shara grop says
testosterone is not the only factor
affecting sporting performance I would
say that you know having a higher
testosterone would be a similar
advantage to having a long arm span or a
long torso and swimmers preposterous and
regressive is half three-time Winter
Olympian Elana Mayer's Taylor described
the decision if you say castor Samana or
women like her have a great advantage
because of their testosterone level well
what about Michael Phelps he had longer
arms or he has a better lung capacity or
he's got feet like flippers does that
mean we shouldn't allow him to compete
sporting heavy hitters like tennis
legend Billie Jean King and Martina
Navratilova have also weighed in
the ruling as unfair but there are
others such as British Olympic swimmer
Sharon Davies who've been vocal in their
criticism of the manuals I think it's
really important that cats have realized
and actually we need to start protecting
female sport you know that it has to be
a level playing good so manias response
has been brief and dignified for a
decade the I double AFIS tried to slow
me down but this has actually made me
stronger she said there's no doubt
summoner has a rare genetic ability one
she once celebrated not penalized and on
that issue the world Medical Association
has joined the debate urging doctors
around the world not to implement the I
double-a if regulations because they say
they are medically unethical Gail
alright Debora patta thank you reporting
from Johannesburg